[Musique]
bonjour François ba bonjour les
militaires de sangaris soupçonn donc
d'abus sexuel sur des enfants à bangi en
centraafrique les accusations sont
particulièrement graves si les faits
sont avérés c'est ça qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire sur ce type d'affa peut dire
quelque chose de très simple s'il y a
des manquements aussi
ignoble que ceux qu'on
signale ces manquements doivent être
pour poursuivi et doivent être punis
avec la plus extrême rigueur et
j'imagine que tout le monde sera sur sur
la même ligne exprimera le même jugement
al la justice française enquête
vraisemblablement depuis de longs mois
il aura fallu attendre c'est sur la fois
d'un rapport interne de l'ONU hein ce
n'est pas rien il aura fallu attendre
que qu'elle soit révélée dans la presse
britannique l'armée c'est la grande
muette le silence est-il toujours de
rigueur dans ce type de d'affa faire
benah il ne l'est pas on est en train de
voir que dès l'instant qu'il y a des
faits de cette gravité ça s une fuite
forcément il y a ici ou là
des communications j'imagine j'imagine
que il faut d'abord et avant tout que
les faits soi prouvés et de ce point de
vue-là nous sommes nous aussi en attente
de ce que les enquêteurs de l'armée
française diront mais aucune aucun
silence et aucune inaction en face de
fait d'une telle gravité même on risque
de fragiliser des troupes qui sont en
opération en opération spéciale sur le
surzone il y a pas de fragilisation
lorsque des faits aussi ignobles sont
commis s'ils sont avérés alors l'affaire
éclate quelleironie he le jour même où
François Hollande donne un coup de pouce
aux armées une rallonge de de près de 4
milliards
d'euros sur 3 ans c'est le bon choix
François
Baayou soutenir les efforts de l'armée
c'est nécessaire on ne peut pas baisser
la garde lorsque le monde est aussi
dangereux qu'il l'est lorsque les
menaces sont aussi importantes lorsque
les risques sont avérés comme ils le
sont et nous avons la chance et la
charge nous la France d'avoir la
possibilité de répondre par des actions
militaires c'est une chance parce que
nous sommes un des seuls pays du monde à
avoir cette capacité et c'est une charge
parce que tout le monde voit bien
évidemment que ça coûte donc euh on ne
peut que
approuver les choix qui sont faits
lorsqu'ils maintiennent l'effort mais je
voudrais ajouter une chose oui euh je
pense que cette cette contribution euh
ne doit pas empêcher de réfléchir à
l'organisation de nos armées euh je vais
prendre un exemple que nous avons tous
les jours sous les yeux l'opération
sentinelle celle qui organise les
patrouilles de les patrouilles de de
soldats dans les lieux publics dans les
monuments officiels l'opération
sentinelle elle est évidemment très elle
occupe beaucoup d'hommes mais ces
hommes-là sont des professionnels
qualifiés formés à PO nous avons la plus
grande base d'hélicoptèr de combat
d'Europe et ce sont des personnels
extrêmement qualifiés depuis des
mécaniciens de haute volé jusqu'à des
servants d'appareils informatiqu et
numérique de vision noctur et cetera
est-ce que c'est le travail de
professionnel aussi qualifié que d'aller
euh faire de la Garde statique dans les
lieux publics vous voyez bien qu'il y
aurait une toute autre organisation pas
le place non je pense que simplement il
pourrait être mieux utiliser que c'est
que que on met à la charge de l'armée
euh de
l'armée opérationnelle d'intervention on
met à sa charge des un travail
nécessaire de surveillance qui devrait
être accompli par une autre organisation
de défense civile vous savez bien que
les États-Unis ont la garde nationale
par exemple c'est-à-dire des des
personnes pens qu'on pourit des
réservistes en France ouais je pense
qu'on pourrait utiliser des personnels
qui seraient moins formés à
l'intervention extérieure et à tout ce
qu'elle comporte comme technicité et que
ce serait une meilleure utilisation de
la ressource humaine et des capacités de
nos armées et aussi évidemment que ça
serait moins cher alors François Baayou
une partie de la droite 3 années après
l'élection présidentielle ne vous
pardonne toujours pas d'avoir appelé en
son temps à voter François Holland
Nicolas Sarkozi en tête le modèle le
modem le Mouvement Démocrate est-il
aujourd'hui compatible avec l'UMP je
vous pose la question parce que vous
êtes en plein préparatif des élections
régionales et bien c'est très simple il
y a un courant il y a
tout cela n'a aucune importance et la
polémique politique habituelle et je
suis pas très accessible à la à la
polémique politique habituelle ça vous
cha pas d' brardé dans des meetings tout
cela n'a n'a strictement aucune
importance euh mais regardons le fond
parce que c'est le fond qui est
important il y a dans la société
française dans la démocratie française
un courant d'opinion qui est un courant
que j'appelle
central qui est un courant réformiste et
modéré qui ne veut pas qu'on entraîne la
France notre pays tout entier dans une
espèce d'affrontement interne de
division dans lequel on dresse une Parti
de la France contre l'autre parti pour
tout un tas de raisons et bien c'est ce
que je dis depuis plus de 10 ans et que
je maintiens et la preuve que c'est un
succès c'est que vous m'invitez
régulièrement pour le
répéter et donc et donc
c'est parce que c'est une sensibilité
que ressentent beaucoup de
Français qui veulent qu'on soit
équilibré dans les réponses qu'on donne
au défi de notre temps équilibré ça veut
dire qu'on est inflexible lorsqu'il
s'agit de faire attention aux menaces et
au risque mais qu'en même temps on
refuse de couper la société ou de ou de
de souffler sur les braises qui ne
demandent qu'à flamber dans une société
où il y a des sujets qui vous le voyez
ça c'est vot définition de ce courant
central qui va o de Monsieur jupet à
Monsieur Vals par exemple quelque chose
comme ça des ns des sensibilités de cet
ordre
or vous me demandez est-ce que vous êtes
compatible mais bien sûr je suis prêt à
travailler à tout instant avec tous ceux
non avec tous ceux qui respectent ce
cette exigence d'équilibre et qui ne se
laisse pas aller ou qui ne choisissent
pas d'aller à le le l'excitation des
divisions du pays c'est une société en
en crise elle est vous savez bien
qu'elle affronte des mutations immenses
on ne peut pas et on ne doit pas en
faire un lieu d'affrontement interne un
pays c'est une unité c'est comme une
famille et voilà exactement pourquoi il
y a des personnalités qu'importe leur
étiquette avec qui nous nous sentons en
phase et prêt à travailler d'
devant qui nous disons attention la
politique c'est aussi une incarnation
des femmes et des hommes donc en clair
vous ne pouvez pas aller avec Monsieur
vquier en ronalp au vergn ni avec
Christian estrzi en Provence à cô d'Azur
parce qu'ils incarnent cet autre versant
que vous aimez moins en fait alors dans
la période où nous sommes comme vous
l'avez dit à juste titre qui est une pré
campagne ces élections viendront dans 8
mois on a le temps nous avons le devoir
de présenter une autre approche et une
autre cons des des listes et des
candidatures donc
je pose une question à quoi cela sert-il
d'annoncer que le Front National est la
cible et l'ennemi numéro 1 si c'est pour
reprendre exactement ces mots ces
phrases et ses obsessions c'est à qui là
non vous savez très bien à
quoi à quoi et à qui je pense et donc à
quoi cela sertil il faut une cohérence
en tout cas nous nous avons besoin d'une
cohérence qui présente devant les
électeurs si on veut en effet se séparer
de ces obsessions qui présentent une
autre approche une approche qui ne ferme
les yeux sur rien mais qui en même temps
ne se laisse pas entraîner à
cette perpétuellement verser de
l'essence sur le feu ça signifie quoi
François Baayou parce que l'interview
est presque achevée malheureusement
Nicolas Sarkozi doit clarifier cette
future UNP les républicains peu importe
ligne idéologique de leçons aux autres
je parle de l'attente de millions de
Français qui avec qui je me sens en
phase et même si vous voulez que je
représente dans le débat politique
national et qui disent écoutez nous
avons des choses précieuses à défendre
et nous ne voulons pas nous laisser
entraîner à avoir un pays qui est
perpétuellement dans cette excitation de
ce que les gens htent au fond d'eux-mêm
qui est en effet l'envie de cibler et de
détester des compatriotes parce que nous
avons
question ultime et brève réponse si
c'est possible vous voyez toujours
François Hollande euh non je ne l'ai pas
vu depuis
longtemps c'est pas fini c'est si
François Hollande veut rencontrer les
responsables politiques bien entendu je
le verrai et si Nicolas Sarkozy veut
voulait rencontrer les responsables
politiques bien entendu je le verrai
parce que je considère que nous sommes
les uns et les autres coresponsables de
l'avenir du pays on a besoin de
travailler en ble et c'est peut-être la
marque de fabrique différente que cette
enfin cette manière de compréhension
mutuelle et de clarté dans le débat que
je porte dans la politique française
merci François Baayou merci